nelson monfort avec laurent baffie sur
la scène de ma mère 50e services et
campana paiera quoi c'est vous le dîner
de cons mais bien leur apathie qui va
année la donne
[Applaudissements]
lolo baffie mon lolo ça
et mais nelson mes frères sur la tête de
20 jeux tilt a tenu au diesel propre
histoire
nelson sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
que tu vas jouer dans bart debie on
attend pas à moi je prends moi je
tenterais bien merci le jeu de l'oeil
johnson en tout cas tu sais que tu es je
suis très content que tu sois là enfin
en tant que t'es pas venu en plus de
quelques souvenirs ensemble
ohlala non c'était la terrasse donnant
sur la terrasse n'a jamais entendu est
ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
chanson comme ça en aquarelle va oui
c'est à dire sans musique et d'orange
alors à son avis derrière d'accord alors
que les notes sur l'ardoisé longs mois
déjà c'est un grand nom
j'espère que c'est là qu'elle s'appelle
l'orage ça parmi d'autres orages et vous
faire la version courte parce que dure 4
minutes 40 est sûr que faire l'orage
prochain déjà heureusement qu'on s'aime
bien on m'avait caché la présence de
laurent je commence à croire et on avait
caché le témoin de la pluie et non pas
du beau temps beau temps me dégoûte me
fait grincer des dents le bel azur me
met en vain je garde le grand bonheur
qui me fuit donner sur terre je le dois
au mauvais temps jol d'oise et jupiter
il me tomba d'un ciel d'orage et par un
soir dr hamda gueule il a pas fini
[Applaudissements]
tonnerre de brest avec décrypte putois à
lui ses feux d'artifice ce bon escient
de cette couche en chemise de nuit
ma voisine affolé 20 frappeurs à gbagbo
en réclamant mais bon je fais j'adore
brassens à ben alors donc ça pour moi
c'est un grand oui non si je vais vous
résumer en un mot ce que tu fermes ta
gueule résume plus à chanter de nelson
monfort avec logo bâti sur la scène de
ma mère c'est comme si mon ami ses
copains à pire acqua ccc la chaîne pour
j'adore mais c'est voulu ruiner de
combes coup de coeur d'un gâteau peau
qui est très présente ce soir je l' ai
jamais vu aussi présente dans l'édition
mais ce cas là c'est alors qu'elle vient
de perdre son mari elle est courageuse
c'est vrai qu'à tout vol vous êtes
extrêmement hypocrite parce que c'est
vous qui avez validé cette nuit moss et
pour tout deux te donne alors sa mienne
ils s'en foutent
ah non ou sans appel sans retenue
j'appelle ça un déguisement
à
[Musique]
adecco
ou chez nous ça fait 15 jours qu'on l'a
retiré le sapin alors et c'est wasquehal
et moules pourtant tient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chaussure enguirlandé ouais c'est un
sondage qui a été réalisé auprès de 1000
80 personnes non mais si mes amis mais
il ya quand même eu les personnes qui
veulent plus voir ma gueule mais la
vraie la vraie chose c'est que on
propose toujours une liste exactions
dans la liste en feu mais je soupçonne
testa et hanouna vous êtes sûr moi je
n'ai pas envie de voir tout cas si la
question est posée voulez-vous - voire
donc il faut répondre oui non mais c'est
vrai que vous avez connu très populaire
ils vont répondre vous auriez teanotoga
a vengé avec qui vous aimeriez mois
voire vous par exemple aux pays d'iroise
fait rigoler
moi je peux voir ta gueule chez d'accord
[Applaudissements]
merci bon de sondage
[Musique]